to be fair yeah but the thing is is that
yet you you are absolutely right I know
what to do
faith work with faith without working
said he's an easier one nothing changes
if nothing changes
you ain't change then nothing's gonna
change you want to feel better do
something different you stop that's it
I am there well good congratulations you
bought him dope
stop it before you have a stroke I'll
tell you a friend of mine a guy I know
it's not a friend of mine but a guy in
orem Lee talented man had a stroke when
he was drinking and he's still alive
he's still around and he can say and
that's it you want to be that guy oh
really
yeah he was successful sure that's why
we tell him and he thinks that stroke is
gonna kill him I'm like no it's true
doesn't kill you it keeps you you you
were debilitated for the next 30 years
of your life and I know this because my
dad had one all right and he's still
alive and he can't move I don't get it
my all my grandparents were paralyzed
from the neck down because of a stroke
my grandmother was for 30 years couldn't
leave her house because she was always
paralyzed she couldn't feel anything
that you get you you're in possession of
some information and it seems I am no
that's why I'm saying it out loud
because I I'm sorry for yelling but yeah
yeah okay all right but I'd I'm in no
way intimidated so it's very I just let
me just it might be me okay sorry and so
yeah I I this reason why I'm saying it
out loud it was to pick up because I
know what is going on and it's not I'm
not blind to it even when I lash out on
kalila right in my head I go you just
lashed out why why did you do that she's
just being nice she even before you got
here she says walk the dog and I just
lashed out you know and I feel your pain
though I honestly I don't want you thank
you that I'm known thank you like I just
just don't though what yeah just don't
I'm not you said like I have kids right
yeah I think I don't want to lash out
sometimes and I
like see for the first 10 years of a
kid's life all you do is put their
[ __ ] shoes on oh my god wearing a
[ __ ] Jersey yeah yeah you think I
don't want to yell and scream about
their shoes and sometimes I admit I've
been a little touchy about shoes
but a lot of times I have not done that
and just don't do it just don't do it
you can feel it it doesn't mean you're
not gonna feel it feel it but you don't
have to do it yeah yeah yeah it's like
sometimes I want to drink but I but you
but I want to say this though is but
you're approaching it especially in
recent times has a real recovered man in
sobriety and you're you go to meetings
and you're and you're very healthy right
and I'm not like that so right right so
right now I want to get to the point
where you're at and that's um I think my
new well there's awakening what I want
to do useful I think then the piece of
information that will help you with that
you can do it right now this is the this
is the instant gratification the
addictive people like us this is the
great news for us you don't have to wait
six weeks for it to take you can be
better right now right [ __ ] now just
say I'm gonna be better enough I'm gonna
be better now and just be better right
now I'm gonna say it now oh [ __ ] right
now I'm gonna be better right for the
rest of this day I am NOT gonna lash out
at the beautiful woman who is deluded
enough to love me oh that's that's
here's a I'm sorry for standing no
that's good but is good you're right
you're absolutely right because this
thing is that many years ago it's cold
man
cooler finger man that's a
right you know when I was in high school
and when I was so I got sober when I was
in high school I was a junior right and
for six years of my first year years of
sobriety back then right
I couldn't get any women they wouldn't
look at me even in meetings maybe when
no one would look at me I was like at
this little shy kid I wasn't doing
comedy at the time you know I was a
working guy right and I used to go I
used to dream in bed like I just want
any woman to like me right and now cut
through many years later mm-hmm
I have a beautiful beautiful engine way
above you you way above my right yeah
good look at me right good for you and
yet you know I you know I lash out on
her and I do things and it's just like
it's really it's just crazy John you
know crazy Joe yeah where are you right
now
you know you know you're in the closet
you're not really you're not far gone
you you're still cognitively you're with
us yeah yeah you drive that way yeah
okay it's fine just as long as you know
how the [ __ ] mechanics of the car
works all right how's your kid good all
right good thank you um yeah so you're
right like I used to pray about someone
someone like that and she's a great this
was this woman here she just she really
just absorbs a lot of [ __ ] from me
mm-hmm and she deserves way better
[Music]